here's the deal I'm about to drop some
mad things you miss from the new movie
date but before I do if you're
interested in winning some free C's
world merch in my free merch giveaway
watch this entire video and you'll find
out how bill has some posters in his
room and I was able to identify a couple
of them as gremlins and Beetlejuice why
is this significant well I think these
posters both have double meanings behind
them the first is a foreshadowing of
bills future you'll find that after
facing their fears in the movie that
none of the losers are losers anymore
they all go on have very successful
careers perhaps the most successful of
them though is Bill Dunn Boro who grows
up to be a horror writer like me but
without the stupid goatee but it's cool
to see that bill does have an interest
in horror as a kid and that leads into
his occupation as an adult
on a sidenote pretty much every Stephen
King novel has a protagonist who's a
writer a method he uses to project
himself into his work muschietti and his
art department could have chosen any two
horror movie posters to hang on bills
waldo so why did they choose these for
one bill still a kid time these are both
more kid-friendly horror movies that
came out in the 1980s but I think
there's a reason that these were chosen
as opposed to say ghostbusters
let's look at gremlins it's a movie
about these little things that change
into other more scary things and in this
movie it's shape-shifting abilities are
on full display one of which being the
transformation that it does with its
teeth when feeding off the fear of the
children it seemed like it took some big
inspiration from Barbara's
transformation in beetlejuice
how the face kind of peels back to
reveal these rows and rows of
razor-sharp teeth especially that scene
where Pennywise is about to feed on Stan
I was getting major vibes
and Burton classic this next one is
really only a thing you missed if you
haven't read the book or at least if
it's been a while during the beginning
of the film you may have heard Bill
muttering the following phrase he
thrusts his fists against the post and
still insists he sees the ghost it comes
back again at the end of the film I
believe what this is is a coping
mechanism that bill uses to help with
the stutter and it's something that
helps him overcome Pennywise in the book
because his stutter is directly linked
to his fear of it it's not that bad at
first but it gets worse when Georgie is
killed and whenever his fear of it
increases the stutter gets worse
remember when he has the courage to go
into the 29 niebolt house after they
discovered that it's the old well house
and it's connected to the sewer he gives
his friends a speech
and Richie even comments on him having
not stuttered through any of it that's
his courage that allows him to stand up
like that so when you hear him say the
phrase he thrusts his fist against the
post and still insists he sees the ghost
without stuttering you know that he has
grown in the face of fear in order to do
so and that's what weakens it I would
expect to hear more of that phrase when
his childhood stutter comes back in
chapter 2 there were a lot of little
nods to events and characters from the
book that were touched on in the movie
but didn't need to be fully expanded
some of these things had their own
chapter in the book but I think the film
did a nice job of only including what
was necessary as not to overwhelm the
viewer here are a few of those
references Ben researches the ironworks
explosion a catastrophe caused by it in
the early 1900's he also looks up the
black spot fire which was a nightclub in
Derry during I want to say the 1930s
that was a hangout for a lot of
african-american men at the time it was
burned down by a racist faction with
only a few survivors one of which being
Mike Hamlin's dad who passes the story
on to his son the relevancy of that in
this movie is debatable because Mike's
parents actually do die in a fire prior
to the events of 1989 and the whole
racism subplot is not really so
applicable with this taking place in the
80s one of the reasons that Henry Bowers
hates Mike so much is that Henry's
father held a great deal of racism
towards Mike's father and that racism
carried down into
it's possible that some of the hatred is
present in this movie because we do see
Henri single out mic a couple of times
the first being just before the rock
fight and the second being when Henry
catches up to Mike as the losers are
descending into the well and nearly
kills him I didn't notice any
specifically racist remarks though let
me know if he felt any of that tension
in the comments back to some of the book
references many of the victims were only
called out by name or at least had their
names show up on missing posters I
noticed that a couple of these were
actual characters from the book like
Betty rips in' and Edward Corcoran I
tried to read all of the missing posters
to make connections but I may have
missed some of them given that I have no
way of pausing this movie in the
theaters so again chime in the comments
and let me know what you saw I'm
genuinely interested one location that
is brought up but I don't think was
actually seen on screen is the standpipe
which is kind of a landmark in Derry
which is connected to the stream in the
Barrens and the sewer system the only
reason I bring it up is that it's
probably more than throwaway reference
as it's something that's likely to come
into play in Chapter two that's all I'll
say for now at one point
Pennywise encounters Ricci and uses the
line beep-beep Richie which is a phrase
that the Lucky seven always uses in the
book
whenever Ricci doesn't shut up it
doesn't come up a whole lot in the movie
but Richie does still run his mouth a
lot the reason I wanted to bring it up
was that I feel like it kind of takes on
a new meaning here with how much of a
potty mouth Richie is in this movie the
beep-beep
could represent the redacted expletives
speaking of Richie did anyone else catch
that Nightmare on Elm Street was playing
on dairies movie theater marquee that
movie came out in 84 I don't know if it
ever came back into cinemas in 89 but
you would think there would be a good
reason for putting that up there in the
wrong year I thought for sure Ritchie's
fear was going to be Freddy Krueger and
that it was going to take the form of
Freddy but it turns out that he's just
afraid of clowns
one other note on Ritchie at the school
when Richie walks by the gang of bullies
Patrick Hawks deader the one who later
goes after them with the makeshift
flamethrower gives him this creepy smile
and licks his lips
one thing this movie was very good at is
telling a lot of backstory visually
Patrick is one messed up a kid who gets
off on hurting others and has weird
violent homosexual tendencies at one
point in the book he actually molest
Henry Bowers which is why I think he's
actually the scariest human character he
doesn't get that far in the movie but
that little lick of the lips at a boy
who is substantially younger than him
that tells us that something is not
right about his character there were a
couple things that were different from
the book but I think actually added to
some of the character arcs in the movie
for example while Stan is Jewish in both
the novel and motion picture his
religion plays a much bigger part now
Stan is studying for his Bar Mitzvah and
his father is the rabbi of the temple
but were given the idea that Stan isn't
really a big believer because he hasn't
been studying his Torah portion in fact
the blessing that he's having trouble
with is actually just the Prarie you
have to recite before opening the Torah
so it's like the easiest one because it
always comes up but he can't even get
through that the reason I think this is
kind of a brilliant change from the book
is that the whole basis of Stan's
character is that he's the last one to
truly believe in it he even says that
things that they're all seeing aren't
real until the niebolt
house encounter and it hits him the
hardest once he believes in it he's
probably the most scared of it and right
after that happens we're led into the
montage of the middle of that summer
where he actually has his Bar Mitzvah
his belief in it's mirrors his faith in
his religion in my things you missed
videos on the trailer for this movie I
talked about the meaning behind the
graphics on some of the kids t-shirts
and how metal can now play the part that
rock and roll played in the original
upon seeing the movie I have another
example of that during the rock fight
belch wears a t-shirt reppin a demo CD
that Metallica put out in the 80s called
metal up your ass the graphic features a
hand holding a sword coming out of the
toilet perfect choice for a movie about
a dangerous clown creature who also
comes out of the sewers let's talk more
about that clown at the end of the
basement scene Pennywise his eyes roll
back in his head before he sinks back
into the water
remember how I pointed out that in the
teaser Pennywise his eyes didn't reflect
in water and then in the official
trailer they fixed it and some of us
were kind of disappointed because the
Iowas boy looked kind of cool well maybe
this was kind of redemption also Bev's
eyes do the same thing at the end when
Pennywise kidnaps her and she's floating
above the ground her eye sockets are
just white so that may have been saying
that penny wise was controlling her I
have more on that floating thing so I'll
get back to that I noticed a couple
things when bill goes into Georgie's
room in a previous video I pointed out
the circus animals on the wallpaper
behind bill as it turns out that's part
of Georgie's room but it's not just the
wallpaper the whole thing is themed like
a circus that's kind of creepy when you
take into account the fact that it is
using George's and image as a puppet to
trick bill throughout the entire thing
you almost wonder if penny wise attacked
Georgie first for a reason the other
thing I noticed was the Lego turtle that
bill finds in his brother's old room
which was one of the few references to a
celestial being known as the turtle who
is an opposing force against it the
turtle is kind of slyly written into the
book characters will find themselves
thinking about the turtle without really
knowing why in the movie one of the
characters brings up the fact that they
think they see a turtle in the swimming
scene and I'm not entirely sure because
again I can't pause yet but I'm pretty
sure I saw a turtle sticker on one of
Beverly's books these references are
nothing more than Easter eggs though
because the primary scene in which the
turtle gives advice to bill known as the
ritual of chud is not a scene in this
movie the turtles rival who the kids
refer to as it but whose true form is
known as the deadlights does make a
brief appearance when Pennywise tries to
eat Beverly and its face peels back she
looks down its throat and sees three
bright lights this is somewhat different
than the form that were used to seeing
the dead lights in they appear to be
more of a force within Pennywise as
opposed to their own powerful entity
nobody in the movie ever uses the word
dead lights so they make their way onto
the silver screen in a much more subtle
way this next one I didn't notice until
the last scene of the movie
in a previous things you missed I
pointed out that Beverly wears a key
around her neck and speculated what it
might be for many and I mean a lot like
666 billion of you pointed out that the
key is uncut so it couldn't actually be
used for unlocking anything after seeing
the movie I still have no idea what the
significance of the key is but I noticed
another piece of jewelry that Bev has
it's a ring with an anchor on it
what do a KERS do they sink and after
countless cases of you'll float - you'll
float - you'll float - the group
eventually finds that Beverly floats as
well after being abducted by Pennywise
but because of the love and dedication
of her friends they're able to find her
and pull her back down out of harm's way
in a world where all of the victims
float she's the one who sinks she's the
anchor in that final scene after the
promise and Bev tells what she remembers
from when she was afloat and says she
had a vision of them when they were all
much older in their 30s this is a
foreshadowing of the sequel when after a
27-year rest
Pennywise re-emerges and the losers are
called back to Derry to fulfill their
promise and vanquish it and that ties in
to the last thing you missed which is
really only a thing you admit if you
didn't stay for the credits because
penny wisest laughter can be heard at
the end of them signaling that the fight
isn't over yet but the fact that there
was a title that said chapter one
probably should have given it away
already if you didn't catch on from that
I don't know what's wrong with you one
thing that I liked about this movie was
the look of it it looks very sharp and
now you too can look sharp in this
dashing sea Z's world t-shirt that's
right I'm giving away a free t-shirt to
one lucky winner to celebrate my 100th
video all you have to do is follow C's
world underscore horror on Twitter and
retweet my post containing the
video there will be a link in the
description and I'll pin the tweet for a
while to official contest rules
freelancer must live within the 50
United States dancer available store
sizes are medium large extra large when
it will be contacted via Twitter direct
messages to collect shipping information
shooting information will be used for
addressing packages in kept confidential
when it will be chosen at random when
will have seven days to claim prize
contest will run for 27 days expires
October 4th 2017 entrance must comply
with YouTube community guidelines in
terms of service YouTube and Twitter and
not affiliated with this contest nor do
they sponsor this eg to Twitter and I'll
liable for anything pertaining to this
contest but wait were prohibited robert
austin did the music for this video he's
got a whole array of creepy clown music
on his channel go check it out and
subscribe if you're interested as for me
I've done 6 videos about this movie here
on the channel and when the trailer for
chapter 2 drops you can count on the
things you missed episode from me until
then I've got plenty of great content
plan you don't want to miss it so
remember to subscribe to see ZZZ world
for new Horrors every week ring that
death bell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive